dans le stade olympique dont le centre
d'abidjan
des milliers de partisans acclament le
président ivoirien alassane ouattara
officiellement investi pour la
présidentielle d'octobre
le chef d'état de 78 ans brigue un
troisième mandat alors qu'il avait
exprimé son intention de passer le
relais à son premier ministre amadou gon
coulibaly
mais son successeur désigné brutalement
décédé début juillet d'un infarctus
contraignant alassane ouattara revoir
ses plans et à présenter sa candidature
a été rappelé à dieu
hannah kinney terminé le conseil des
ministres le même jour nous étions à 12
semaines de la date de l'élection
présidentielle qu'il était difficile
primaire une annonce qui provoque la
colère de l'opposition
alors que le gouvernement ivoirien a
interdit les rassemblements jusqu'au 15
septembre
officiellement en raison de la pandémie
de coronavirus de nombreux manifestants
bravent l'interdiction pour protester
contre ce troisième mandat qu'il juge
contraire à la constitution
début août des violences ont émaillé des
manifestations contre sa candidature
faisant six morts et une centaine de
blessés en réponse les partisans de
ouattara affirment que la révision de la
constitution adoptée en 2016 a remis les
compteurs des mandats à 0 nous trouvons
que cette décision est inacceptable
parce que nous pensons que le président
ouattara essaie de s'accrocher au
pouvoir
nous avons décidé de mêler des actions
vigoureuses sur le terrain nous allons
employer tous les moyens pacifiques et
démocratiques démarche des sittings en
tout cas toutes les manifestations pour
ces beaux opposé à ce troisième mandat
quelques heures avant l'investiture du
président ivoirien pour un nouveau
honda la commission électorale
indépendante a rejeté les recours de
l'ancien président laurent gbagbo et de
l'ex chef rebelle guillaume soro qui
contester leur radiation des listes
électorales laurent gbagbo a été
condamné par la justice ivoirienne à 20
ans de prison pour le braquage de la
banque centrale des états d'afrique de
l'ouest pendant la crise électorale
ivoirienne de 2010 mais l'ancien
président a été acquitté en première
instance par la cour pénale
internationale
il vit désormais à bruxelles et souhaite
rentrer au pays pour briguer à nouveau
le pouvoir
de son côté l'ancien chef rebelle
guillaume soro a vu sa candidature
rejetée à la suite de sa condamnation
par la justice ivoirienne à 20 ans de
prison pour recel de détournement de
deniers publics et blanchiment de
capitaux
l'ex chef des jeunes patriotes charles
blé goudé l'opposant akossi bendjo
également condamné au pénal en côte
d'ivoire ont eux aussi dénoncé leur
radiation des listes électorales au
lendemain de l'insurrection militaire au
mali
le gouvernement ivoirien semble craindre
que le soulèvement populaire malien ne
galvanise l'opposition dans le pays